small businesses and their employees
have paid a
heavy price during the pandemic there
are nearly
32 million small businesses in the u.s
employing
more than 44 47 percent of workers the
pandemic has forced
more than 400 thousand to close the wall
street firm goldman sachs is
installing ten thousand help still
wanted signs
on capitol hill they represent
businesses that graduated
from their ten thousand small business
program over the past
10 years and show that government
assistance is still needed goldman sachs
chairman and ceo
david solomon is in washington to lobby
lawmakers on behalf of small businesses
and joins us now good morning mr solomon
thanks so much for being here
we really appreciate it thank you very
much for having me i'm thrilled to be
with you this morning
i want to get to small business in a
second but i want to ask you about a
letter that
that you signed yesterday you were one
of 200 business leaders who signed it
calling on congress to accept the
electoral college results in that letter
you wrote that attempts to thwart or
delay this process run counter to the
essential
tenets of our democracy there should be
no further delay in the orderly transfer
of power
what made you sign on to that
well i think i think right now the
discussions around
moving forward are very very important
we i congratulated the vice the vice
president-elect now the president-elect
back in november after the election and
with all the issues we have as we're
trying to move past the pandemic
and move forward to help people who need
help around the country i think it's
time for us to move forward
and get focused on the issues at hand we
uh there is another round of of stimulus
money coming to small businesses
uh but but uh many of them ninety
percent
uh have already used up the money they
got from the first round they're in dire
straits
how are small businesses surviving and
what more needs to be done at this point
well it's really amazing to see how so
many small businesses are being nimble
trying to pivot trying to find ways to
move forward but one of the reasons
we're here today and we're so committed
to the 10
000 small business program is these
businesses continue to need help
and if you look at the placards that are
across the capital lawn this morning
they talk about a number of issues that
small businesses still need support and
help on obviously this additional round
of ppp funding is very helpful obviously
making sure that the ppp loans don't
have a negative tax impact
is helpful but i'll highlight three
other things that the small businesses
that we've helped over the last decade
are asking for first better access to
capital and something like the restart
act i think can be very helpful with
that
they need better access for their
workers to health care because health
care can be such a crippling cost
and in addition they also need support
with
child care because they need to be
working they need to be focused on their
businesses so they can keep their
businesses moving forward so those are
just a handful of the things
that small businesses are telling us
they need continued support on given the
pressure they've felt
during this pandemic mr solomon i want
to talk about your desire to help
specifically black business owners your
own survey has showed that they have a
harder time getting the business loans
and what needs to be done to fix that i
understand that you want to do something
about that specifically
we've we've tried to find ways to get
capital
into the hands of business of color it's
been much more difficult
for small entrepreneurial businesses of
color to access capital gail
and in the context of that we through
ppp deployed about 700
million dollars of capital and with this
new ppp round
through cdfis and mission-driven lenders
we're prepared to commit at least
another 500 million dollars of capital
to get that capital access to these
small businesses
and these are small micro loans that can
help these small businesses
bridge through over the course of the
coming months until we get to the other
side of the pandemic
you talk about the importance of getting
to the other side how how critical is a
vaccine to the economy mr solomon do you
think
i i think it's i think it's very
critical that we get the vaccine
into people so that people feel safe and
we can move forward
with the economic vitality that's so
important to this country so
i'm watching very closely as you all are
as we all are
it's important for us to get to the
other side of the pandemic and the
vaccine is an important step
in that process yeah and and your
additional commitment that you've
announced today
amounts to how much well we we committed
back in december we announced that we
commit another 250
million dollars to the 10 000 small
business program so that we could bring
another
10 000 businesses through it in the
coming years
and in addition now that the new round
of ppp is in place
we're prepared to continue through cdfis
and mission-driven lenders
to deploy another 500 million dollars of
capital in small loans to help these
businesses sustain
david solomon of goldman sachs thanks so
much for being with us we appreciate it